le scandale sanitaire des pizzas buitoni
continue d'enfler après décontamination
sur sa gamme de pizzas fraîches up le
rappel massif de pizzas buitoni ses
pizzas à l'origine de graves problèmes
de santé chez des enfants c'est la gamme
des pizzas bella napoli qui est
aujourd'hui épinglé une mère de famille
de 34 ans a été contaminée par la
bactérie e.coli après avoir consommé une
pizza une nouvelle plainte a été déposée
cette semaine par une jeune femme de 34
ans qui a été contaminés à la bactérie
escherichia coli deux jours après avoir
consommé une de ses pizzas qu'on cache
pas qu'il a pas mangé pour s'arranger la
trentenaire qui souffre de maux de
ventre et de vomissements a porté
plainte contre lui tony et nestlé
propriétaire de la marque à ce jour ces
pizzas sont toujours en vente en grande
distribution alors nouveau scandale pour
une autre gamme de pizzas buitoni la
marque pourra-t-elle se relever
on va regarder ce qui s'est passé pour
christina donc cette mère de famille de
34 ans elle consomme sur mars à
perpignan une gamme épisode la gamme
bella napoli chebbi tony et présente
deux jours plus tard des symptômes très
inquiétant au regard doux
qui a pas mangé ça quand je n'ai jamais
connu dans la com ça j'avais deux
pacsées en fait les échos les juges à la
clé un médecin est venu dans ma chambre
et elle me l'avait demandé si j'avais
mangé une pizza c'est bien les gens me
l'avait montré
tu les pizzas de but rennais alors
ce que ne comprennent pas le sou le mari
est l'avocat de christine haas et que le
principe de précaution ne soit pas
appliquée que les pizzas de la gamme
bella napoli ne soit pas retirer comme
l'ont été celles de la gamme fraîcheur
c'est vrai que c'est la question qu'on
s'est tous posé un regard des son mari
lui est scandalisé car cette gamme de
pizzas est toujours présent dans les
rayons on ne sait pas la même fraîcheur
en fait ma forme était contaminée par
une autre pizza et ces pizzas sont
toujours en vente actuellement dans le
marché c'est le principe de précaution
qui est totalement totalement bafoués
dans cette affaire à la fois par lester
à la fois par les autorités sanitaires
et par la justice
alors gilles mois ya quelque chose que
je ne comprends pas et je voudrais
dénoncer un vrai scandale alimentaire
aujourd'hui je suis allée acheter des
pizzas au magasin j'ai acheter des
pizzas qui sont des pizzas donc acheté
dans paris danse sais pas si je cite le
magasin le bon voilà dans un grand
magasin et acheter donc une pizza bella
napoli celle dont on parle là n'ont pas
encore été retirés on est d'accord mais
j'ai acheté aussi trois pizzas fraîches
up ses pizzas fraîches ap hockey
incroyable alors au 18 mars on nous
avait dit elles doivent toutes être
retiré moi je me suis dit peut-être
qu'après ils en ont fabriqué et je vais
trouver fabriquer le 25 avril et valls a
pas une date dessus pas une provenance
on a tous fouillés avec les équipes ça
veut dire que quand vous achetez ça rien
ne vous dit que vous n'achetez pas une
pizza qui a été fait avant le 18 mars et
qui peut contenir la bactérie e.coli
mais c'est quand même hallucinant j'ai
le ticket de caisse aujourd'hui acheter
à 15h30 quand on parle de scandale
alimentaire il faudrait peut-être que
les marques se mobilisent et moi je suis
d'accord avec ce père de famille
christine a été hospitalisée six jours
c'est très grave elle a une deuxième
bactéries en plus de e-coli on doit on
ne doit plus pouvoir acheter ces pizzas
ciré ni bella napoli ni même ses frais
chap c'est un danger pour les gens je
les ai prises comme ça je me suis dit au
moins je les ai retirées mais il y en
avait eu plein j'avais envie de tout
prendre je trouve ça hallucinant c'est
incroyable franchement c'est vrai que
c'est fou et vous avez trouvé très vite
tout de suite et on arrive je suis allé
au rayon surgelés j'ai l'habitude
d'aller là bas je les ai trouvés il y en
avait beaucoup et je me suis dit mais
sait on pas possible quelle date il ya
aucune date n'a aucune garantie est
habilité à l'homme est trop curieux
aucune traçabilité ces sages et rallye
c'est quand même fou la marque n'est pas
interdite aujourd'hui gilles l astre est
en train de faire c'est un appel au
boycott de la marque n'est pas bien et
ça reste des cas isolés tu met en danger
une marque et donc tu m'envoies une
entreprise gamme et des gens partis qui
peuvent potentiellement se retrouver au
chômage ça reste c'est évidemment
terrible ce qui se passe il ya deux
morts c'est yves langenier au trot et la
mort grâce à l'assurance add-on bas
et appelé au boycott d'une marque voilà
ses marques et des sentiers but tony bou
pardon ce week-end il ya descente il ya
des centaines de salariés du tonus et
que vous avez quelqu'un non mais c'est
pas bien d'appeler à boycotter d'avoir
quoi la marque devrait certes mais
pourquoi mais retire au moins les
fraîcheurs oui mais d'accord mais
d'abris comme ça on peut acheter des
fraises y sommes hier matin on en voit
partout ailleurs c'est peut-être que les
d'absence
c'est pourquoi ce que tu fait appel à
boycotter de marque devant des millions
de gens c'est l'arrêt ne vient pas d'eux
m'avait fabrication si la manges tu as
une chance sur deux penaltys
l'appelle pas au boycott sans armée au
boycott tu viens de le dire toi même la
mange pas de toi même tu vas pas aller
prendre une pizza de cette remarque mais
n'a pas ce que tu te ronge j'ai un doute
et moi je vais même aller plus loin je
pense que la marque va s'effondrer parce
que moi mère de famille je ne vais pas
prendre le risque là où il a acheté une
pizza et de la donner à leur fils est
par ailleurs j'irai même plus
aujourd'hui acheter une pizza surgelée
parce que je me dis si dans les faits
beaucoup de mal
mais je suis je suis certaine que c'est
les autres marques ont baissé de 3 mois
j'ai coché une différence entre les ces
légions libre de consommer ou non et
vouloir interdire une marque appelé au
boycott et je trouve que les méthodes de
gildas de élise lucet de la foir'fouille
islam
metropcs communications de bétonnière a
été à la hauteur elle est très mauvaise
justement je pense qu'ils doivent
communiquer communiquer expliquer la
raison de ces cas qui restent des cas
isolés voilà il ya deux morts s'élève
dormir ans est mort de trop ouais et
voilà vouloir boycotter alors vouloir
tout boycotter je suis désolé parce
qu'il ya un accord je vais faire il ya
eu deux morts pour les pizzas but tony
on veut boycotter la marque hier on
parlait du vaccin et ses effets
secondaires il ya eu des morts il ya des
effets secondaires personne ne parle de
boycott je trouve ça un bon alors là
l'attenté de
savoir quoi et pourquoi coûte pourquoi
enfin tu es en train de parler du coach
tu compares une maladie qu connaissait
mal avec grax a à une pizza ou délit
mais dans des conditions d'hygiène
épouvantables avaient alors péri des
produits qui sont soupçonnés d'avoir des
comptes non des effets secondaires
fortement désirable voire très grave
vous êtes rémunéré par bétonné ou pas
ok
guillaume a raison il est lapidé en
mémoire exemple derrière qui est ma
raison il ya des emplois des ray lahood
géraldine a raison c'est que la
communication est catastrophé pourquoi
ne pas dire ne vous inquiétez pas les
pizzas qui sont aujourd'hui dans le
commerce sont pas prêts et le mois de
mars là on voit des numéros il ya la
date de péremption ya leur 9h27 il ya
202 40 sur 100
par exemple ils nous disent par par
exemple les 852 vous pouvez les manger
c'est simple pourquoi n'y a pas des gens
de britten de but tony proviennent de
bruit tony pourquoi ya pas de gens qui
viennent parler ils sont les directeurs
ils sont les dirigeants qui a eu de
drame est encore une dame qui se
plaindra pourquoi les mecs ne prennent
pas le micro c'est facile ils viennent
là ils arriveront d'autres questions qui
savent pas ça ce qui s'apparente à ce
que la pizza n'a été faite mais n'est
pas ce que ça veut dire la jeunesse qui
n'a pas confiance en leurs produits et
les navarrais damas qu'elle est en
danger alors faut arrêter voilà ça voilà
simplement faut changer de nom faux la
nouvelle élise lucet là
notre garcia internat ils ont regardé ya
qu un numéro et là la layan en laye à la
nature la dernière la belle anna polina
sinon quand même non mais franchement
guillaume vous êtes irresponsables c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être à l'intérieur
de cette pizza et
riadh fehri dangereuse et vous balayer
ça d'entrée en disant on ne doit pas
appeler à boycotter
j'appelle pas du tout à l'abri causé
j'appelle à la responsabilité
en face d'un scandale sanitaire peut
être le plus grave en france 55 à deux
morts pas directement relié mais
probablement le pôle sanitaire qui
enquête dans toute la france et vous
vous dites continuer à acheter des
pizzas
sont encore en état végétatif
bien sûr bien sûr mais évidemment oui si
la marque doit être boycottés ça doit
pas être gilles verdez qui doit le
décider pardon désolé il ya des
autorités pour ça il ya des fins de
mendicité sa lancée en alerte c'est bien
huilé l'aviation et de la communication
et on a raison valérie la communication
de la marque ya des numéro un communiste
2022 18h20 c'est 1 131 980 qui commence
à marchaux islamique est douce et autres
et si tout n'est pas tout il ya bien des
numéros là il ya bien un numéro sur la
pizza sur salat ya bien un numéro est
sûr évidemment cette technique est là
napoli 8 évidemment séné d'eux mêmes sur
salat y en a des
implications
sur la fraîcheur c'est ce qu'il faut
c'est communiquer tu peux pas mettre les
salariés comme ça dans la merde je pense
que c'est vrai je rajoute que la marque
nous disent là les pizzas de la
catégorie fraîcheur ou de la catégorie b
le napoli 2 avec les numéros de scellés
si vous avez ça chez vous jacques ses
numéros de série la voulait rapporté
vous voulez jeter et et qu'on fasse ça
rappelle dépit de certains profitent à
plein de mire survie tudor ils
s'envoient des accords stratégiques
c'est l'épuisement de la colère c'est à
dire voilà il ya une enquête et puis le
temps se dilue la justice passera donc
sais pas combien d'années et il continue
à fabriquer en ayant fermé l'usiné du
nord de caudry continue à fabriquer des
pizzas mais non parce que s'il n'y a pas
une réflexion globale s'il n'y a pas des
actions s'il n'y a pas des consommateurs
qui se mobilisent ça va continuer le on
avait parlé la dernière fois de la
saleté dans ses usines ça c'est
absolument inacceptable
il faut changer tout ça regardez voyez
mes ailes est fermé
vous n'avez pas à vous en mêler
j'ai pas tomber des caisses qui l'a
jamais admis non franchement j'y vais je
pense exemple coco bio c'est une boîte
qui a qui ont pas beaucoup de gens a
évidemment eu des problèmes concernant
la belle anna polina pour l'instant une
percée une personne vêtue la maternelle
seront qui dit qu'elle a mangé la pizza
y ait eu ou qu aucun d entre eux ce
qu'elle avait dans l'estomac et ce
qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils ont trouvé
sur l'épisode on déjà non non non non
non ils n'ont pas trouvé de 2,2 de virus
ou de bactéries dans la belle anna
police se désole l'agathois richie
gellar dans son sillage et rate on a
plus de l'antre la sono sur elle peint
sur la pizza pour l'instant il n'y a pas
à l'onu une [ __ ] qu'est vraiment
rassuré le pas sur la pizza mais c'est
la patte qu'est ce que tu on sait
qu'elle est belle à la police
est honnie bravo tu perds magnifique on
n'aurait pas vu le document il ya une
enquête d mais là il manquait il n'y a
pas de il a dit que vous devez manger
quoi j'ai mangé une pizza but tony alors
peut-être que peut-être que c'est ça
exact peut-être que c'est ça et donc
tour à peut-être on va fermer une usine
des usines choisies et batterie la
maîtrise à vous entendre on fait manger
les enfants les mères donneuses
ils ont fait exprès qui s'offrit des
lots qui l'ont qui vont fourguer les
mauvaises pizza et son pack et on a
conscience jamais dans le doute on y
tient risque je dis aux matières jeudi
que la communication effective ils ont
mal communiquée mais pas non plus ce
service aurait effectivement je trouve
ça pas bien parce qu'il ya des gens
derrière qui bat yeux voilà mais là ça
va pas bien mais jamais si ça va très
bien géré a très bien doute gigantesque
sur ses pizzas en marais vu une usine
qui a été fermée qui est dégueulasse y
en a une chronique les autres à peu près
sûr du même niveau et pour le moment
quand bien même quand même ce que tu
dirais serait vrai pour le moment il ya
un doute et pardon le doute il faut le
mettre du côté de la sambre
je suis pour les emplois faisant des
régionales ne vit pas de l'emploi demain
demain tu es malade qui veut manger quoi
des radios députés adoptent rapidement
le dire on en est là et vous déconnez
répondant dès maintenant je sais jamais
quand tu vois les gens préfèrent
commettre ami tu te poses la question
des paires de seins mais il n'est pas
clair de femme il y eut plusieurs fois
maille
dorée risque d'aliéner je fais ce que tu
donnerais
de deux enfants oui non mais non non la
seine à paris sauf que la différence du
match que tu connais pas les ongles oui
mais les notes yvon les courses
maintenant qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
prennent plus aucun produit surgelé
iphone d'aucun produit près préfabriqués
donc avec nos cd des zones entières de
commerce qui vont être d'essayer lacroix
lui-même je ne mentionnerai pas vingt
mille en train dernière à cause de ça
les gens à ce qu'il appelait la
technique et soit la guérison peut pas
tout jeter avec l'eau du bain comme ça
c'est pas noir ou blanc toujours les
blancs noirs vont à ta de la nuance toi
ouais c'est la nuance quand on se sait
jamais à l'avancé
ouais j'en parle à lyon s'annonce à
anissa toi ce que tu manges red epic
d'abus tony maintenant à apprécier
paraît que l'histoire des kinder en fête
dans un an tous on va oublier quoi nous
avons racheté quoi on sait qu'à la
raison c'est vrai que l'on peut danser
ni savoir qu'est ce que faisait ce que
disait le fait que voilà ils vont
attendre que ça se passe c'est pour ça
qu'on remet les usines dégueulasse hiver
quand même des efforts oui c'est quand
même dans le bon sens à l'inflation
c'est pas sûr ils sont dans le déni
total parce que vous avez vu les photos
de cette usine de caudry qui est fait
qu'affirmer ils ont ils ont reconnu que
les photos avaient été prises à mais ils
ont dû s'est jamais aussi sale
d'habitude vous rendez compte comme un
gamin qu'il y avait l'envié laver les
mains c'est incroyable ils s'adressent
déni total il se passe à gauche qu'il
faudrait pour la communication c'est
qu'ils nous montrent les nouvelles les
nouvelles des nouvelles photos de l'
usine complètement nettoyée pour assurer
c'est ça nous rassure rien à dire ils
vont nettoyer bon
m
enfin jean [ __ ] week ce qu'il veut
sont quand même préciser que la bactérie
qui a été trouvée la nouvelle shigella
tue deux cent mille personnes dans le
monde par an donc cette maman s'est
passé non mais non répond je dis pas que
ça irait pas de corrélation en arrive à
cette marque et la dame de grâce